Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
So when I was a kid,
there was a popular joke construction called the Russian reversal.
The first time I heard a Russian reversal
was in a Miller Lite commercial in 1985
where the comedian Yakov Smirnoff said
In America, you can always find a party.
In Soviet Russia, party always finds you.
But the joke is actually much older than that.
It was used in a 1938 Cole Porter musical,
and in a 1960s episode of the show Laugh-In where the joke was:
In America everybody watches television.
In the old country, television watches you.
Ha! That's funny!
Everyone said before our televisions started gathering
reams of information about our viewing habits.
Be careful who you laugh at, friends,
for in time, you may become them.
But, right,
Russian reversal jokes were basically low-level,
xenophobic weapons of the Cold War.
Trying to get Americans to believe
that their country where you could always find a party
and watch television,
was perfect, in purported contrast
to life in the Soviet Union.
There were, of course, also American reversal jokes.
My favorite being:
In the Soviet Union, people sometimes rob banks.
In capitalist America, bank robs you.
And there were jokes that refuted both ideologies,
like this one from Moldovan-American educator Emil Robbie:
Under capitalism man exploits man.
Under communism, it's the other way around.
Of course, these days, the Russian reversal has been memed to near-extinction,
like so much else on the internet.
But, I still find the joke construction really, really interesting
because, it starts out with you having agency
over something
and then ends up with that something having agency over you.
Like in a way Michael Pollan's famous
observation about corn is a Russian reversal joke.
He pointed out that, while it's true that corn has adapted to our human interests,
if you look at it from corn's perspective,
we have adapted a lot to corns' interests.
Like, we've changed our habitats and our diets and our travel patterns
to make corn more plentiful
and when you look at it that way,
corn kind of becomes the farmer
and we kind of become the crop.
And when you start looking for these jokes,
you see them everywhere.
Like, for starters, in Shakespeare.
In Richard II, the king says:
I wasted time, and now time doth waste me.
There's a Winnie the Pooh story
where Piglet says he's so small that he doesn't fly a kite,
so much as the kite flies him.
And in the Oscar-nominated feature film Boss Baby,
[Oh John....]
the titular character says, "Either you run the day,
or the day runs you."
Slightly off-topic, but the book that movie is adapted from is excellent.
Anyway, I used this construction a lot in my book Turtles All the Way Down:
You're the storyteller, but you're also the story told,
you think you're spending money,
but the money is spending you, et cetera
Because the book is about what happens when
you feel like you're not captaining the ship of your so-called self.
And I think what I love most about Russian reversals is
that they can reveal how weak we are
before the forces of time and the wind and money and everything else.
And in general I find it helpful to take
a kind of Russian reversal style look at
any big force in our lives.
Like, take the social internet's algorithms, for instance.
Are they informing us, or are we informing them?
Or free markets:
Do markets exist to make human lives better and more efficient,
or do human lives exist to make markets better and more efficient?
Of course, the Russian reversal can create a false dichotomy.
You can waste time 𝑎𝑛𝑑 be wasted by time.
And, as we all know now,
you can watch television
and be watched by your television.
And maybe there's no tension at all in some reversals.
Like, I guess it's possible that whatever makes markets more efficient
is good for human lives
and whatever is good for human lives makes markets more efficient.
But in my experience, anyway,
that kind of ideological rigidity rarely holds up
to careful scrutiny.
And I like the Russian reversal
because it asks us to consider where the power
is really centered in our discourse.
Sometimes the answer is obvious,
the humans who plant the corn
have much more power than the corn that gets planted.
But sometimes it isn't;
is the real power with the Twitter user
who chooses what they tweet
and who they follow
or with the algorithm that decides which tweets the user actually sees?
And is the real power with the people who make markets work
or with the markets that make people work?
I don't think those questions have easy answers,
but I do think that looking at them backwards has a way of telling us
truths we otherwise might miss.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.